[Music]
the tokyo olympics made history even
before they began
they're the first games to ever be
postponed
they're also on track to be the most
expensive summer olympic games
ever so when japan won its bid to host
the olympics in 2013
it said that it would cost around 7.4
billion dollars but before the pandemic
the budget had risen by 70
to 12.6 billion dollars and that's not
really surprising
later japan's board of audit said the
cost would exceed 20 billion dollars
that was before pandemic related costs
set in
so the biggest costs for the olympics
are the facilities
the new national stadium here in tokyo
as well as
several other large facilities aquatic
center
and others that have been built for the
games and those cost over three billion
dollars
and there was about the same amount that
was spent on renovating
other facilities to bring them up to
standard for the games
so the whole thing in terms of venues
was around 7.5 billion
and the other big cost is the
operational budget for the olympics
it's around two billion dollars almost
every olympics ends up going over budget
bids are usually an optimistic estimate
what's different
in tokyo of course is that we've had
this one year delay
and we've also had a pandemic so the one
year
postponement meant that there are
additional costs incurred
for having to renegotiate contracts for
venues
for having to keep staff on for an
additional period
and various other things which added to
the overall budget
and the public risk from the pandemic
hasn't gone away so the tokyo olympics
are now proceeding with covet
countermeasures that require new costs
manpower and infrastructure together the
postponement and covid measures will add
an estimated 2.5 billion dollars to the
game's budget
according to event organizers on top of
those direct costs kovit is also taking
away much of japan's ability to recoup
what they've spent
ticket sales would be around 800 million
dollars
and now they'll be close to zero because
there'll be almost no spectators
and there'll be almost no income from
visitors of course
athletes and officials who have come
here from overseas might spend some
money but nothing like
the amount that the organizers were
hoping for from
spectators who would fill the stadiums
buy merchandise you know spend money in
hotels and restaurants and that could be
some of the economists say you know as
much as two billion dollars and now
that's lost
corporate sponsors have contributed
around 3 billion to the games
and the ioc has contributed 650 million
dollars to help cover the extra costs
resulting from the pandemic
still that leaves the bulk of the cost
of japan with little ability to recoup
in the short term but even the most
expensive summer olympics in history
pales in comparison to the overall cost
of the pandemic
japan has spent around 800 billion
dollars
on stimulus packages three of them
because of covid the pandemic is
obviously the
the most expensive thing to deal with
here it's not the olympics
but if the olympics makes the pandemic
worse
and there has to be you know new
stimulus measures
those could be far larger than the
actual budget of the olympics